nate you know before covid you could get
your groove on with
david perrico and his pop strings
orchestra
that was at cleopatra's barge at
caesar's
or at myron's cabaret at the smith
center well those venues
may still be closed but the internet is
wide open
[Applause]
[Music]
this high energy pop fusion band can
pack a las vegas dance floor
any night of the week except of course
during a pandemic
[Music]
well i thought it was going to be
temporary i
wasn't surprised but then when i saw the
the strip actually
shut down then it became more
realistic of this is going to be serious
and we still haven't played since march
14th
music producer director david perrico is
also a composer
trumpet player and band leader of his 14
piece pop strings orchestra
music pros who play with strip
headliners like celine dion
diana ross and rod stewart now without a
stage to perform on
thanks to kovalev
you know we're based on our ticket sales
we're based on
how many people in the room uh we're
based on selling
cocktails
[Music]
lead vocalist lilly arcy is also david's
wife
they spend a lot of time working and
playing together but being sidelined at
home for nearly a year has been
well challenging
so many other couples let's use that
the playful pair just collaborated on a
popular public service announcement
you might have seen on tv
david composed the music and lily sings
the lyrics for the unlv sponsored ad
reminding us all to mask up kind of a
fun thing i'm like whenever he goes out
to the store i'm like
please don't leave me
but david and the band are anxious to
perform together again
this time on a virtual stage the
orchestra is tuning up for their first
pay-per-view performance
and so this is a chance to kind of
reconnect with all the people
that we love
[Music]
but the dance floor will have to be your
living room with
serve yourself cocktails
[Music]
i'm already getting in the groove you
guys well the live stream pay-per-view
concert
is next friday night that's january 22nd
it's at the space that's mark chinook's
the space
and the time is at 6 p.m now the cost is
23.50 that includes the fee for the
ticket
what a great price we've got that link
on our website eightnewsnow.com
and uh david wants to thank john saxa
and finley cadillac for sponsoring the
event to help cover the cost
because you know they got to pay camera
guys and sound crews and stagehands
a little bit different venue for what
they're used to performing
uh with and so they're already working
on another streaming performance in
february
to honor black history month so they're
saying if this one goes well and fingers
crossed
that the fans get back in and they watch
them live stream and they love it
they're gonna keep doing these until
they can get back on stage
bring the audience back in person and we
can all
kind of get back to normal whatever that
new normal is going to be but
he they really miss playing with uh
all of us sitting in the seats or
jumping and grooving on the dance floor
guys
well you know nowadays with tvs being
what they are you can stream it on the
tv it'll be like you're right there in
person alex you can have them on a big
wide screen and it's
just almost as good as being there not
quite the same but close
i know well just nice to see them
getting to do what they love and
nate we all miss watching entertainment
so it's nice to see
that also uh did you guys see that
commercial on tv because the first time
i saw it i actually stopped what i was
doing and i watched the entire
commercial name oh what about the mask
yeah yeah very well done sherry they did
a great job with that one
they sure did and it was so neat that
they could uh collaborate together on
that and use both of their talents
together
uh and also lily does message grams as
elsa from frozen and we're going to talk
about that next week
and a lot of the musicians in the band
also do you know their side businesses
like wedding events and you know they do
those little micro weddings so
they play as duos and trios and so
they're all doing what they can to stay
busy and have a little income
until the orchestra can really get back
together and perform
as their cohesive group david's actually
handling nine different bands and
orchestras right now to try and keep
busy so
he's got his hands full but they want to
get back on stage